live aus schuld im aartal ein ganz
besonderer tag für viele menschen hier
denn heute vor einem jahr hat sich das
leben für viele hier schlagartig
verändert heute vor einem jahr kam die
flut nicht nur in schuld sondern in
vielen orten hier entlang der aa dem
eigentlich kleinen und sehr ruhigen
fluss und auch in nordrhein westfalen
die flut kam von anfang an mit einer
enormen wucht mit der viele nicht
gerechnet hatten ort für ort und hat
viele dieser orte geflutet und einfach
vielen menschen die existenz genommen
viele häuser zerstört und das leben auf
den kopf gestellt mehr als 180 menschen
haben in rheinland-pfalz und
nordrhein-westfalen ihr leben verloren
und fehle eben haus und existenz und
arbeiten bis heute daran dass
wiederzubekommen deshalb berichten wir
heute hier live aus schuld einem der
betroffenen orte denn heute gedenken die
menschen zusammen und wir nehmen euch
mit ihr könnt natürlich fragen stellen
die ganze zeit während dessen live im
stream und kommentieren oder auch per
mail und ich versuche so viele davon zu
beantworten wir sprechen mit menschen
hier aus schuld die betroffen sind und
betroffen waren von diesen wassermassen
wir sprechen auch in schalten mit
menschen anderswo entlang der aa und
auch in nordrhein westfalen
und wir schalten auch live zur rede des
bundespräsidenten der heute mit den
menschen gedenkt und als erstes möchte
ich jetzt hier in schuld mit dem
bürgermeister von schuld mit helmut lucy
sprechender jetzt zu mir kommt hat auch
schönen guten tag herr
lucy was ist das für ein tag für sie
heute ein jahr später wie fühlt er sich
für sie an und was bedeutet der physik
es ist natürlich ein trauriger tag für
mich und ich glaube auch für alle
betroffenen menschen hier im gesamten
gebiet weil vor einem jahr kam diese
flut ganz überraschend für uns fallen in
diesem ausmaße und
man kann sagen innerhalb von sechs
sieben stunden
war das schon wieder vorbei und
man hat dann in der nacht die verwüstung
gesehen und die zerstörung die diese
flutwelle mit sich gerissen hat die war
dieser abend diese nacht für sie wo
waren wir also ich hab bis 2 uhr nachts
an der kirche gestanden und habe dem 300
millionen zugeschaut weil hier ja alles
überflutet war es war
bis zur mitte von der brücke hat wasser
gestanden hier war überhaupt kein in
koffern mir hier waren konnte man keine
menschen mehr retten weil es war ein
leben in gefahr für die hilfskräfte und
von daher haben die menschen die hier
nachts in den häusern gesessen haben und
mit taschenlampen geleuchtet haben schon
um ihr leben gebangt muss man ganz
ehrlich sagen und was das wasser
angerichtet hat kaum vorstellbar wenn
man jetzt hier hinter uns ihre kleine
avid und was das wasser also in
rheinland-pfalz angerichtet hat da
zeigen jetzt einen überblick von anna
bligh
es sind unvorstellbare wassermengen die
in den kleinen orten an der ahr wüten
schuld altena bernau diese ortsnamen
stehen stellvertretend für das ahrtal
das auf rund 40 kilometern länge von der
flutwelle verwüstet wurde innerhalb von
stunden verwandelte sich der
beschauliche fluss in einen
lebensgefährlichen reißenden strom in
rheinland-pfalz sterben
135 menschen davon 134 im aartal eine
person stirbt in trier in den fluten des
flusses kühl auch in trier und in
anderen eifel regionen gibt das
zerstörung und leid
766 menschen werden während des
hochwassers in rheinland-pfalz verletzt
unzählige überleben nur weil sie sich
auf dächer oder bäume flüchten viele
andere können nicht mehr rechtzeitig
evakuiert werden und ertrinken darunter
zwölf bewohner einer
behinderteneinrichtung in sinzig
rund 9000 gebäude werden zerstört
straßen und brücken einfach weggerissen
die nacht vom 14 auf den 15 juli 2021
wird die katastrophenregion noch auf
jahre prägen
live in schuld können wir mit dem
bürgermeister mit helmut lucy jetzt
sprechen herr lucy wie steht denn schuld
ihr ort heute ein jahr später da
sie sehen ja immer noch die verwüstung
wir hätten gedacht im grunde dass es
schneller vorangeht vor allen dingen
auf kommunaler ebene dass die regierung
bundesregierung auch die landesregierung
die gesetze nicht so beibehält wie sie
sind weil es ist ja eine katastrophe die
in deutschland einzigartig war und da
hätte ich mir schon gewünscht dass die
gesetzgebung da ein bisschen zurück
gefahren wäre mit mit ihren gesetzen
hätte den aufbau hier immer etwas
erleichtert so dass auch die privaten
immobilien besitzer eine bessere chance
haben ihre immobilie da wieder
aufzubauen wo sie denn wieder errichten
wollen denn es ist ja teilweise sowie
häuser die in der stehen geblieben sind
die haben ja ein bestandsschutz aber die
neuen immobilien die jetzt aufgebaut
werden die in der nähe der a liga die
können nur also hochwasser geschützt
aufbauen das haus auf stelzen setzen
oder kein keller mehr machen so was also
da hätte ich mir diesbezüglich schon
erleichterungen gewünscht auch im
kommunalen bereich weil es jetzt mit den
behörden hände regeln geht wie man
weiter verfährt die anträge die liegen
auf wochen monate lang bei den behörden
und sie sehen ja hier ist kein bagger am
ring und die bevölkerung die wünscht
sich dass man irgendwann mal hier
anfängt dass man bescheid und mit den
kommunalen strukturen wieder beginnt
diese vernünftig aufzubauen es ist alles
in planung wir haben seitens der
gemeinde alles gemacht planungsbüros
alles eingeschaltet und
ja jetzt geht's ans
genehmigungsverfahren und danach geht es
ja nur das ausschreibungsverfahren aber
dieses vereinfachte
ausschreibungsverfahren es bis jetzt nur
noch bis ende des jahres begrenzt und
dann muss nur europaweit ausschreiben
und das wollen wir natürlich vermeiden
dass wir jetzt noch sukzessive in den
genuss kamen vor ändere das komplette
ausschreibungen raus haben sodass denn
die fachfirmen die man dann bekommt mit
dem wiederaufbau beginnen können was
sind die größten herausforderungen vor
denen sich irgend nämlich gerade stehen
ja größte herausforderung war bis jetzt
unten auf der anderen seite steht die
komplette brücke weggerissen die ist von
1910 die hat auch einmal unter
denkmalschutz gestanden und der
denkmalschutz ist ja eine schwierige
hürde zu nehmen da mussten wir extra
einen wasser geologisches gutachten
anfertigen lassen das haben wir diese
woche der
der behörde gezeigt und noch
dokumentiert und da hat man festgestellt
also wenn die pfeiler in der nicht
gestanden hätte er so dass kleiner
verglasung hätte stattfinden können der
wert der wasserspiegel um zwei meter 20
tiefer gewesen
wäre zur katastrophe war und dass die
häuser nicht so in mitleidenschaft
gezogen werden oder wurden und jetzt ein
jahr später wie geht es den menschen
hier in ihrem kleinen ort rund 700 leute
leben hier ja wir sind ja wieder
einigermaßen nach samara strukturen
zurück gekommen wir haben
eine infrastruktur mit licht wasser und
es ist natürlich so dass viele
infrastruktur zerstört ist so zum
beispiel unserer bäckerei unser
dorfladen unser metzger und da hängen
die unsere unser dorfgemeinschaftshaus
nicht mehr da und da hängen die leute
doch sehr dran waren metzger und ein
bakterium auch die waren wirklich
vonnöten weil wir eine super intakte
infrastruktur hatten darauf
gemeinschaftshaus wo viel viel gefeiert
wurde darauf hat jetzt jeder nachweis
kann kleiner vereine mehr darin proben
und keinen ton gruppen mehr wir haben
keinen jugendraum wer also es ist schon
na ja wie soll ich sagen nicht zufrieden
stellen aber im gleichen atemzug muss
ich auch sagen es wäre typisch zu
behaupten dass schuld in ein oder zwei
jahren wieder aufgebaut wäre oder würde
ich bin jetzt mittlerweile der meinung
erst habe ich mal geschätzte 45 jahre
aber ich glaube das wird schon sieben
acht bis zehn jahre dauern mittlerweile
danke helmut lotti bürgermeister von
schuld für den moment ich war letztes
jahr auch in schuld und bin ein jahr
lang immer wieder hierher gekommen und
habe eben auch menschen kennengelernt
die es trotzdem mit ganz viel kraft
geschafft geschafft haben hier wieder
ihr zuhause aufzubauen und eine familie
die ich getroffen und begleitet habe ist
familie diehl und in die sind auch
gleich bei mir und zuvor schauen wir
einen kurzen beitrag
vor einem jahr als das wasser kam und
die flutwelle den ort schuld traf wurde
auch das haus von anna diehl und ihren
eltern zerstört das untergeschoss
komplett überschwemmt das wasser stand
höher als anna groß ist alles war weg
das haus unbewohnbar aber familie deal
wusste sie wollen zurück kommen zurück
an die ahr nach hause der weg dahin war
hart
paar momente wo es mir dann auch
psychisch immer ein bisschen schlechter
ging weil ich wollte halt nach hause und
es war alles sehr anstrengend und
stressig ihr kleines dorf ist immer noch
nicht wie früher
die wenigen geschäfte die es gab wurden
zerstört
welche der bäcker oder sowas aufmacht
muss das ist etwas mehr wie früher ist
es dieses was früher alltäglich ist
wieder alltäglich wird
wenn anna und ihre schwester zum
aussichtspunkt wandern wird das ausmaß
der zerstörung deutlich
auch heute ein jahr später dort hinten
das ist ihr haus
zu hause also es auch wenn dreckig ist
und ich glaube ich ist aber es ist halt
immer noch zu hause und weiß ja dass
viel schöner
werden im vergleich zu vielen anderen
wahrscheinlich schon jetzt kennen die
sie kennen ja nun eigentlich das braune
schuld aber wir kennen es ja viel anders
grüner genau so grün und schön soll es
wieder werden wünscht sich an sie ist
auch ein bisschen stolz auf all das was
sie in diesem jahr gelernt hat nicht nur
ganz allein radlader fahren da ist noch
mehr
haben alle viel durchgemacht und
trotzdem sind sie jetzt alle hier und so
ein glücklicher zufrieden und es gibt
schon das gefühl von innerlicher stärke
und weil das schaffen kann natürlich
auch dass man körperlich richtig
muskeln angelegt hat
mit ihrer ganzen kraft haben die idee
ist es geschafft sie sind inzwischen
wieder zurück in ihrem haus
anna ist mit ihren eltern die kompetenz
peter jetzt bei mir und wir können
familie dir fragen wo sie waren heute
vor einem jahr
ich will um die uhr täglich wir noch zu
hause bin dann aber ja später mit
gezwungen zu einer freundin gegangen und
wir sind dann gemeinsam bekannt
wurden erst im gerätehaus und dann zu
bekämpfen da warst du dann in sicherheit
aber ihr habt die nacht sogar im haus in
ihrem haus verbracht was ja bis zum
ersten stock fast geflutet war oder wir
haben noch versucht sachen in sicherheit
zu bringen wird ging
hatte thon verstellbare da die behauptet
wasser da war und man hat der hoffnung
damit ein bisschen noch gerettet gericht
und stiegen mit seiner geschwindigkeit
an wo man gar keine chance hatte waren
10 20 minuten zeit um noch antwort nach
oben zu bringen meine frau war im hause
ich habe noch eine werkstatt wird
versucht und hier bin da noch her etwas
draussen ein guter meter hoch über
terrassendach vom ein frauenhaus
anruf unter rossendorf
zwanzigster bestimmt schon etwas auf
einmal und aber keine chance mehr in die
richtung weg zu kommen dann haben wir
ein beitrag gesehen das wasser war höher
als du groß bist anna und dann ging das
auch irgendwann am nächsten morgen war
es schon weg ging es dann weiter für
euch direkt an das war so schwimmer
sollen 10 11 uhr wird so ziemlich
rückstand hatte vielleicht bis 23 uhr
geschätzt dazu
immer 20 zentimeter runter 25 euro oder
zehn runter und so
haben wir gedacht wäre vorbei und man
hatte ja nur anhaltspunkt wo endet hat
geht das noch ein mitarbeiter geht dann
noch zwei mitarbeiter das war eigentlich
so schlimmste wohl sagt die ungewissheit
wo erörtert hochwasser auf das dahin
gekommen wo man nie mit gerechnet hat
und
ja ich habe euch kennengelernt einen tag
später da wart ihr schon total am machen
wir uns kennengelernt anna da hast du
arbeitskleidung betragen und hast hier
allen im ort auch geholfen nicht nur an
eurem eigenen haus könnt ihr mir so ein
bisschen beschreiben was war hier los in
schuld auch in sachen hilfsbereitschaft
und und hilfe die man bekommen hat das
ist halt jeder jedem geholfen so
nachbarn mit dem man ganz lange nicht
mehr gesprochen hat die waren dann auf
einmal da bzw die nachbarn jetzt nicht
unbedingt die hatten ja selber auch
hier das chaos im haus und ja es kam
dann auch viele bekannte und
haben dann geholfen und nicht nur
bekannte er hat mir auch erzählt dass
waren viele fremde auch die euch
geholfen haben nachher freunde die haben
dann gefragt was ist was können wir euch
helfen wo kommen wir her anpacken und
dann ging es auf einmal ganz ganz viele
viele leute von aus ganz deutschland da
die geholfen haben
und jetzt weiß ich auch natürlich und
jetzt wissen die zuschauer auch ihr seid
ja wieder zurück zu hause wie viel kraft
hat das gekostet wie viel habt ihr dafür
arbeiten müssen
jeden tag
besucht eine woche wirklich zwar noch
einen bayerischen sieben-tage-woche ihr
habt also jeden abend noch am wochenende
in die nacht rheinau
[Musik]
ansporn war war nach einem aus zu sein
das war möglich weil geht morgens ganz
groß im haus kann gern stellt wiederum
und oben ist sie gar nicht mitbekommen
dann kommen oder gegangen sind genau bei
den großeltern habt ihr zwischenzeitlich
bis weihnachten nämlich gewohnt weil das
haus war ja unbewohnbar und dann wart
ihr also mit die ersten die wieder
zurück konnten aber trotzdem weiß ich ja
auch aus unseren gesprächen ihr seid
immer noch total am arbeiten weil wie
ist die situation jetzt gerade was was
fehlt noch alles
werden zum einen haben wir mit
gutachtern kontakt gehabt die
falsche gutachten oder fehlerhaft und
mal wieso der eine sagt sodann so
mussten auch hier neue gutachten machen
dieses buch ist jetzt die letzten wochen
einfach zwei fertig geworden noch
mehrere betroffene gebäude und ja das
ist natürlich auch der finanzielle
aspekt wenn wir jetzt die anträge stellt
auch das dauert wieder ein paar wochen
bis überhaupt nur dann unterstützung
kommt dabei auch weitermachen kann also
irgendwann
sind wir sparen ist ja auch aufgebraucht
und
wird zum eigentlichen ursachen sowie
heizung wird jetzt fertiggemacht oder
neue macht war noch ein provisorischer
holzkessel der überlebt hatte damit
konnte man heizen hat nicht warm war
auch gut aber da war aber
behörde auch irgendwann wieder
normalität
doch dann wieder faktisch ist
also wichtig ist muss man ganz klar sein
ob die hilfe die immer noch kommen
wir haben jetzt noch drei mädels aus
bayern einen der auch schon ein paar mal
hier war hinter hannover kommt er ja zum
außenbereich man herrichten man will ja
auch irgendwann noch mal draußen im
studium schöne wird der sitzen und nicht
nur regionale
und da geht es noch ganz vielen so die
hilfe brauchen sowohl der wahlhelfer
shuttle die immer noch über online aktiv
sind aber auch hier nach braucht
die dachzelt nomaden die auch ganz ganz
viele tun sonstige hilfsorganisationen
die hier noch tätig sind also muss man
sagen dass es auch schon ganz viele noch
wichtig mit den das zelt nomaden werden
wir auch später in dieser sendung noch
sprechen aber an euch zum schluss auch
noch die frage dieser tag heute essen
gedenken später wird hinten in der
kirche hinter uns auch im gottesdienst
sein wie fühlt sich dieser tag ist ein
jahr später für euch an
grundsätzlich schon damit so gut
überlebt haben das in anführungszeichen
nur ein materieller schaden das können
leben gekommen
das eigentlich wichtigste
alles andere kriege und wann wieder hin
so motorisiert ist eigentlich da nur
weil
in meinem leben gekommen ist das kannst
du mit mixa setzen
nur ums leben gekommen darunter
unschuld zu klug können und das ist
eigentlich das wichtigste
alles andere wird wieder hinzukriegen
sagen
konnte was gerade auch noch was agenten
eigentlich nicht mehr
alles klar dann vielen dank an euch an
anna nicole hans peter diehr und die
ganze geschichte auch von anna die ich
ein jahr lang begleitet habe die könnt
ihr finden bei uns in der zdf mediathek
oder auch bei youtube schaut euch das
gerne an es ist eine beeindruckende
geschichte danke schön und
ich schaue auch gleich noch mal was es
noch anfragen von euch gibt aber
zunächst ihr hört jetzt auch schon
hinter mir die kirchenglocken hier
finden also in schuld findet ein
gedenkgottesdienst statt in einer halben
stunde aber eben auch in vielen anderen
orten wird der opfer gedacht die es ja
leider auch gefordert hat bei dieser
schrecklichen flutkatastrophe und später
auch in ungefähr 15 minuten mit der
bundespräsident frank walter steinmeier
sprechen er war heute im aartal und
sagte der klimawandel hat uns erreicht
und eben heute vormittag war er
unterwegs in rheinland pfalz sprach mit
menschen hier vor ort über die flut über
den wiederaufbau und emma zusammen
unterwegs mit der seiner pfälzischen
ministerpräsidenten mit malu dreyer und
er versuchte zunächst auch eine ehemals
zerstörte weinstube in altena und nach
altena werden wir eben auch gleich noch
schalten und sprechen mit meiner
kollegin mit marion geiger und
steinmeier fuhr dann weiter nach
euskirchen in nordrhein-westfalen denn
da auch das wird in unserer sendung noch
thema sein auch nordrhein westfalen war
stark betroffen und dort wird er also in
15 minuten voraussichtlich auch eine
rede halten malu dreyer die liegt
natürlich hier im ahrtal und spricht in
diesen minuten bei einer gedenkfeier im
kurpark bad neuenahr zu der auch kanzler
scholz gekommen ist und ich meine dass
wir da jetzt auch die bilder dazu sehen
müssten oder ihr sie vielleicht schon
gesehen habt und denn weil ich sie
gerade genau ich habe jetzt gerade nicht
gesehen aber ich hoffe dass ihr sie alle
sehen konntet und gehört jetzt also auch
schon hier die kirchenglocken also so
langsam geht hier das gedenken los denn
am abend kam das wasser und ich hab's
angesprochen wir können eben auch jetzt
in einen der orte schalten die auch
frank walter steinmeier heute besucht
hat dort in altena ist meine kollegin
marion geiger marion zunächst natürlich
am anfang die frage an dich wie schlimm
war dein altenahr betroffen vor einem
jahr
ja altena war sehr schlimm betroffen das
ist sehr stark verwüstet worden altena
liegt ein stückchen weiter flussabwärts
von schuld aus gesehen wo du jetzt bist
das wasser hier her braucht ungefähr so
dreieinhalb bis vier stunden
und hier kam aber nicht nur dieses schon
da sehr hohe und viele wasser der aa an
sondern es kam noch viel mehr wasser
dazu durch nebenflüsse der die dann hier
in
altena entschuldigung in altena das
wasser auf eine höhe aufgetürmt haben
die vorher absolut unvorstellbar war
also die ady fließt hier hinter mir das
könnte jetzt nicht sehen weil sie ganz
unauffällig fließt ein ganz kleines
flüsschen und als ich das erste mal habe
ich mich gefragt wo ist nun überhaupt
die a ich dachte das kann doch nicht
diese art sein die hier diese
verwüstungen angerichtet hat die
hat hier um halb sieben abends am 14
juli letzten jahres ein stand erreicht
gehabt der so hoch war wie beim
hochwasser
2016 damals galt es als
jahrhunderthochwasser und die leute
dachten okay das ist jetzt schon schlimm
aber es wird jetzt das wird jetzt
gewesen sein es war dann aber leider
nicht so sondern in den folgenden
stunden ist das wasser dann tatsächlich
auf bis zu zehn meter angestiegen
teilweise sogar noch drüber und hat hier
häuser weggerissen hat autos mit sich
gerissen das war sehr dramatisch zehn
menschen kamen ums leben und sehr viele
häuser sind zerstört worden
der ortsbürgermeister von altena hat
heute bei dem gespräch mit frank walter
steinmeier gesagt dass die ortsgemeinde
hier baumaßnahmen vor hat in einem
volumen von 60 mal gemeindehaushalt also
145 millionen euro muss die gemeinde
ausgeben um allein die kommunen schäden
zu beheben und das sind die schäden von
den privatpersonen ja noch gar nicht mit
einberechnet bei mir ist jetzt einer der
winzer des ortes von altena denn in
altena beginnt der weinbau hier beginnt
das weinbau tal für das die ah ja auch
berühmt ist und lukas sehr man führt
hier das weingut seiner familie das
weingut sehr man in neunter generation
und hatte das kurz vor der flut
übernommen herrmann wir haben sie denn
diese flut nacht an sich er lebt
ja ich kann mich noch sehr gut daran
erinnern weil es sehr sehr eindrücklich
war ich hab auch 216 meter lebt wo das
wasser hier stand bei 3 meter 70 damals
stand die halle noch nicht wo wir jetzt
stehen
wir haben in den wochen vorher schon
extreme niederschläge gehabt so dass wir
uns als winzer eigentlich gefreut haben
und
schon auch von einem späten herbst
ausgegangen sind als es dann hieß es
könnte event hochwasser geben wir kennen
das zwei meter alles kein problem 250
das ist haben wir schon zigfach gesehen
war ich sogar etwas genervt weil ich
vorkehrungen treffen musste also dennoch
weggefahren habe blumen säcke geholt um
als samstag ersatz zu dienen und als ich
wiederkam ist mir zum ersten mal bewusst
geworden dass das hier sehr interessant
werden könnte das endete dann daran dass
wir ich sage mal gefüllten innerhalb
eines augenblicks angefangen haben alles
hoch zu räumen ist vorbereitet haben auf
fünf meter hoch was ja inzwischen auch
gemeldet worden
und dann nur noch unsere unser hab und
gut versucht haben zu retten und
schlussendlich dann auch uns retten
mussten und den nachbar haus
eingebrochen sind
können sie diese gewalt dieses
hochwasser die flut dann hatte bisschen
beschreiben
am eindrücklichsten ist es dass wenn man
bis zum bis zum fußknöchel im wasser
stand teilweise sich schon nicht mehr
auf den auf den füßen halten konnte das
heißt die
das hochwasser ist nicht das problem
diese flut die fließgeschwindigkeit das
war das problem dazu kam natürlich die
ganzen dinge die durch das wasser
geschwommen sind die auch immer größer
wurden bis hin zu schiffscontainern wo
auf campingplätzen halt noch waren wo
man natürlich auch allein durch die
wucht des gegenstand das hätte schon
schon sterben können
wie ging es dann bei ihnen am nächsten
tag weiter wie groß waren die schäden
bei ihnen
ich habe gedacht wir sind opfer eines
raketenangriffs geworden ich hab die
straße nicht mehr wiedererkannt die
friedhofsmauer lag vorne auf dem auf der
straße drauf es war auch gar kein
durchkommen ich guck mir jetzt anders
abzutransportieren
kein auto mehr durchgekommen
und dann haben wir gesagt gut wir müssen
jetzt erwarten bis das ganze wasser weg
ist dann fangen am nächsten tag an da
standen auch schon helfer da und dann
hab ich warum auch immer angefangen mit
der gefriertruhe weil ich dachte da sind
verderbliche lebensmittel drin weil das
ding ist nicht mehr gekühlt und dann
haben wir angefangen und uns dann stück
für stück einfach vorgearbeitet
wie hoch schätzen sie ist der schaden
der ihnen entstanden ist durch die flut
zwischen 1 millionen 15 millionen euro
das ist ja ein gewaltiger schaden wie
stimmen sie ihren wiederaufbau welche
mittel können sie zurückgreifen waren
sie versichert oder nicht
weil sie nicht versichert und
inzwischen sind wir für sich hatte waren
vorher nicht versichert und
haben daher auf private mittel und
spenden zurückgreifen müssen ohne
spenden wäre es noch gar nicht gegangen
das fängt an bei einer sachspende für
materialien die wir zum baum brauchen
und natürlich geldspenden die wirklich
sehr sehr groß auch waren
beziehungsweise natürlich auch menschen
die einfach vor ort geholfen haben und
so dass wir gewisse arbeiten nicht durch
handwerker haben abdecken müssen
man muss aber auch sagen dass das
dadurch dass der schaden so groß ist wie
er immer wieder auch an der stelle
kommen wo wir sagen
was machen wir jetzt wenn die nächste
große rechnung kommt und da kommt
natürlich das thema der zugesagten
hilfen ins spiel wo wir auch als
gemeinschaft auch sehr froh darüber
waren und dankbar waren dass das
wirklich sehr sehr fix angekündigt
worden ist auch in der höhe wo wir
gesagt haben okay dass das reicht
natürlich wussten wir da noch nichts von
inflation von gestiegenen produktpreisen
etc rohstoffpreisen und wir haben auch
geglaubt aufgrund der anfangs euphorie
und weil viel ist doch unbürokratisch
liefen einfach auch niemand gefragt
wurde dass es mit den hilfen deutlich
schneller geht so dass die finanzierung
im prinzip die ganze zeit gesichert ist
sie sprechen jetzt ja auch von den
staatlichen mitteln aus diesem
wiederaufbau fonds oder wo es ja hieß
dass bis zu 80 prozent der kosten für
den wiederaufbau erstattet werden können
wir sind da ihre erfahrungen damit wie
wie funktioniert das funktioniert es gut
ist es so dass sie sich darauf verlassen
können oder haben sie das
schwierigkeiten dabei
selbst bei uns ist ganz unterschiedlich
wir mussten aufgrund unseres unseres
firmenkonstrukt mehrere gutachten
beziehungsweise mehrere anträge
aufstellen insgesamt sind vier stück
alles was den weiblichen teil betrifft
lief über die ddr und das da sitzen eben
mal gewinnst oder wenn es ja kollegen
und das lief auch dann wirklich sehr
sehr schnell und reibungslos also da
sprechen wir von antrag abgegeben eine
woche später ist das geld da dieses
beschworene schnell und unbürokratisch
hat man da auch gespürt bei den anderen
anträgen gerade was den privaten
wiederaufbau angeht und muss mir einfach
sagen dass wir zwar relativ gut die
antrage haben stellen können also ich
fand das jetzt auch nicht unrichtig oder
sonst was das war schon ganz okay aber
die bewilligung hat ewig gedauert einige
bewilligung sind immer noch nicht durch
und selbst dann hat das geld auf sich
warten lassen erst als dann vor ich habe
zwei drei wochen her bald auch mal so
ein bisschen kritischer reporter
berichtet hat an
an die politik an die spitzen der
hagelte ist auf einmal bewilligung das
heißt theoretisch hätte es dafür auch
gegangen gehe ich davon aus
fühlen sie sich denn da auch ein
bisschen im stich gelassen weil es gab
ja dieses versprechen dass es möglichst
schnell und unbürokratisch gehen soll
oder wie beurteilen sie diese abwicklung
der staatlichen hilfen
ich möchte ich möchte nicht tauschen mit
den herren und den damen die da sind
sowohl eine entscheidung als auch eine
ausführung aber muss einfach sagen dass
das kein anderes wort trifft als ein
komplettversagen also ich kann jetzt
weder sagen dass ich mich hier besonders
durchgeführt gefühlt habe noch kann ich
sagen dass ich weiß wie ich meine ganzen
nächsten rechnungen begleichen soll und
genau dafür eigentlich dieses
versprechen da so schnell und
unbürokratisch bist ja ein sehr
bekannter minister der vor kurzem ja
auch geheiratet hat gesagt hat ist es
auf gar keinen fall gewesen das geht
natürlich auch weiter im öffentlichen
wiederaufbau es geht nicht irgendwie
gelder es nützt nichts wenn hier 15
milliarden versenkt werden und es an
einigen häusern hängt die hier einfach
rum stehen immer noch wie zwei tage nach
der flut wo freiwillige helfer ohne den
hausbesitzer zu kennen einfach netter
weise leergeräumt haben aber die buden
jetzt hier um schimmeln und wir dann
eben unsere gastronomie auf machen
sollen wir dann eben die region aufbauen
sollen das wird so nicht funktionieren
und ich denke wenn sich da nicht
schnellstens da spreche ich jetzt nicht
von wochen sondern von tagen
schnellstens etwas ändert dann werden
weitere 15 milliarden hier nötig um uns
um uns am leben zu halten
das werde wollte ich noch mehr fragen
auch zum abschluss sie sind ja hier
nicht alleine sie sind zwar
vorangeprescht sie war noch der erste
der hier in der kelterhalle wie den
ausschank eröffnet hat sie wollen von
ihrem eigenen umsatz leben sie brauchen
eigentlich auch touristen was für eine
rolle spielt die infrastruktur für
diesen wiederaufbau von altem
von dem tal wie beurteilen sie das
drumherum
die essenziell also natürlich ohne
angebot wird hier niemand essen trinken
schlafen
aber wenn das angebot auf dem eigenen
hof stimmt aber drumherum nicht dann
sind hier leute die kommen einmal denken
oh gott wir sitzen hier daneben noch aus
und ich kann ja nicht die ganze zeit in
die halle setzten die tür zumachen nur
der mitte nichts mehr sehen also viele
kollegen und auch ich wir bauen unsere
unsere geschäfte wirklich sehr sehr
schön auch auf modern teilweise auch
nachhaltig so das sage ich mal das
angebot definitiv stimmt auf der anderen
seite ist es aber auch so und auch
verständlich dass die leute also für
mich es verständlich wenn leute sagen
ich will jetzt hier nicht mehr nicht
mehr hinkommen
vielen dank für diese schilderungen
so fiel erst mal aus altena und jetzt
zurück zu dir alles sah nach schuld
tanke marion geiger lukas sehr man das
war sehr spannend für diese
eindrücklichen schilderung über die
situation jetzt für viele hier in den
ort nicht habe auch mal in der
zwischenzeit und eure kommentare
geschaut und lese auch da sehr viel
respekt für die menschen und was sie
hier geleistet haben stefan hopf
schreibt bei facebook alles gute für die
zukunft euer schicksal hat die
bevölkerung in ganz deutschland bewegt
ihr könnt stolz auf euch sein und
man ihnen bei youtube schreibt meine
grüße und größten respekt an jene die
diese familien nun immer noch
ehrenamtlich unterstützen beim bauen etc
waren sind leute ja wahnsinns leute uns
heute eben auch ein tag für viele sich
noch mal zu erinnern und auch zu
bedenken denn hier in schuld und eben
auch in so vielen anderen orten entlang
der ahr war vor einem jahr um diese zeit
also wirklich alles anders das wasser
stieg die pegel stiegen und deswegen
erinnern heute viele an all das was hier
passiert ist auch ministerpräsidentin
malu dreyer hat heute gesprochen und wir
können einen o ton von ihr kurz zusammen
reinhören
ich kann nur erahnen was der jahrestag
der schlimmsten naturkatastrophe die
unser land jemals erlebt hat und die
viele von ihnen unmittelbar durchlitten
haben heute an gefühlen auslöst
bei mir ist noch einmal der
bürgermeister von schuld helmut lucy und
tennessee wir haben schon darüber
gesprochen wie es schult wie es ihrem
ort jetzt geht es war nämlich auch ein
ort der auch bei touristen sehr beliebt
ist das haben wir gerade auch von alten
angehört ist das für sie jetzt auch ein
großes problem dass sie eben weniger
touristen kommen ist die situation also
mit sicherheit werden weniger touristen
kommen weil die infrastruktur doch sie
in mitleidenschaft gezogen ist wir haben
ja unsere pizzeria und alles verloren
und
wir haben noch ein hotel was zur zeit
geöffnet hat
wir hatten ja seitens der gemeinde auch
99 kilometer wanderwege rund um show ist
das ganze
[Musik]
ausgeschildert mit einem qr code
versehen sowie mit dem handy was man
denn der navigation dem weg nach gehen
konnte und man merkt schon dass
bedeutend weniger leute kommen ich weiß
nicht vielleicht aus scham weil sie sich
so fühlen nein ich will jetzt keine flut
tourist sein aber ich glaube dass es
grundverkehrt weil gerade jetzt könnten
die leute kommen weil wir brauchen die
um damit wir leben hier in unserer
gemeinde rein kommt und wir wären sehr
froh wenn auch viele viele leute diesem
aufruf fordern würden und würden sagen
soll wir fahren mal in samstag oder
sonntag und wandern in rotwein schuld
ist sehr attraktiv das stimmt und ich
habe eine frage hier von elias stark
nutzgarten bei youtube und sie fragt
sich wird die politik jetzt endlich
schnellstmöglich dafür sorgen dass die
spendengelder freigegeben werden was
hinter ihre erfahrung her ist
betroffenen also ich kann dazu nur sagen
wir hatten ja seitens der gemeinde hier
einen spendenfonds eingerichtet bei der
verbandsgemeinde adenau wo allein nur
für schuld für die flutopfer 1,9
millionen euro eingegangen sind und wir
sind bei den geschädigten gewesen haben
uns die schädigung angeguckt haben einen
ja mal einen einen antrag katalog
ausgeführt pro jeder seiner schädigung
denn in euro beziffern konnte und die
verbandsgemeinde adenau die hat das denn
so aufgeschlüsselt dass wir spenden
gerne die geflossen sind an die
141 geschädigte zwischen
45.000 euro so unkompliziert ausführte
konnten dass die leute ja schon wieder
neue heizung neue fenster und alles drin
haben also da ist das geld über den
bürger von seiten sehr sehr
unkompliziert geflossen
was jetzt auf staatlicher seite seitens
der esb bank rheinland pfalz
da tut man sich schwer aber man ist
bemüht der verbesserungen einzubringen
was ich allerdings immer noch
ein kriterium für mich ist dass die
leute nur 20 prozent bei der ersten
auszahlung
überwiesen bekommen wobei in nrw schon
40 prozent und wenn einer ein schaden
von 100.000 euro hat und bekommt einmal
20.000 euro das ist ja nur peanuts für
die zweiten 30% bis 50% modellen
vorleistungen treten und dann sagen die
leute ja was für eine bank gibt unseren
kredit und da wünsche ich mir dass die
rheinland pfälzische politik da doch
vincent zu 40% auszahlung kommen wobei
man jetzt überlegt hat in not fern
werden auch 40 prozent ausgezahlt aber
wie bekommt man einen notfall also für
mich nicht vorstellbar weil alle leute
sind im notfall und da müsste direkt
auch seitens der landesregierung
gebühren und das sind auch wer wie viele
eben hier in schuld betroffen wir haben
jetzt die ganze zeit im hintergrund die
kirchenglocken denn gleich beginnt hier
der gottesdienst in denen sie auch
teilnehmen werden werden an dem gedacht
wird was es für sie jetzt heute noch
geplant als ort schuld um gemeinsam
diesen an diesem tag zu erinnern also
wir werden nachher in einer lichterkette
herunter gehen und hier dennoch unseren
dorfplatz in an der trafostation die
performance steht wenn die lichter
anzünden um den leuten zu gedenken die
im aartal gestorben sind
glücklicherweise muss ich immer sagen
übertrifft die ortsgemeinde schuldig
weil wir gott sei dank keine toten
hatten aber wir gelenken auch den toten
im ganzen tal und auch in nrw
ich danke ihnen helmut lussi der
bürgermeister von schuld vielen dank und
wir werden uns wiedersehen und danke
ihnen und es ist nicht nur in
rheinland-pfalz wir haben es schon
angesprochen am anfang der sendung das
heute gedacht wird denn auch dort sind
sehr viele menschen betroffen sehr viele
orte betroffen kamen menschen ums leben
und deswegen schauen wir jetzt auch mal
in einem rückblick in einem beitrag von
torge bode nach nordrhein-westfalen
dreizehnter juli den ganzen tag über
regnete es an rhein und ruhr in strömen
in der nacht zum 14 juli nimmt die
katastrophe schließlich ihren lauf in
hagen geht doppelt so viel regen runter
wie sonst in einem monat und den
nächsten 20 stunden wird der regen nicht
aufhören kleine flüsse wie die filme
werden in kürzester zeit zu reißenden
strömen
in altena wird ein feuerwehrmann von den
wassermassen der lenne mitgerissen
anwohner ziehen den völlig erschöpften
helfer gerade noch rechtzeitig aus den
fluten
ein anderer feuerwehrmann ertrinkt an
diesem tag nur wenige meter entfernt
und das unwetter zieht weiter bad
münstereifel die erft ist über die ufer
getreten und zerstört große teile der
historischen altstadt
noch weitere zwei tage am 15 und 16 juli
setzt sich die katastrophe fort in
erftstadt blättern wird die abbruchkante
einer kiesgrube unterspült und reist
mehrere häuser mit sich wie durch ein
wunder gibt es hier keine toten
erst nach und nach zeigt sich das ganze
ausmaß der zerstörung
49 menschen verlieren in
nordrhein-westfalen ihr leben
und auch in odendorf in nordrhein
westfalen war die lage damals dramatisch
ist der wiederaufbau nach wie vor im
gange und wir können es auch jetzt in
einer karte sehen also in odendorf in
nordrhein westfalen dort hat sich eben
auch haben waren viele menschen
betroffen hat die flut viele menschen
betroffen und wir können dort sprechen
mit meinem kollegen mit ralph goldmann
er steht für uns enorm dorf reif wie ist
die situation jetzt heute in odendorf
und was es damals passiert
ja also auch in odendorf das hört man
vielleicht hier leuten auch schon die
glocken denn auch hier sondern 830 ein
gedenkgottesdienst stattfinden ich stehe
hier amorbach und das kann man
vielleicht mal zeigen hier wenn der
täter hinter der kamera mal runter
schwenkt hier floss vor einem jahr der
eigentlich kleiner bach das ist ein
fluss der fließt in die swiss die
schrift fließt in die erft und der erft
fließt dann in den rhein und dieser
fluss ist komplett außer kontrolle
geraten man sieht hier ist es überhaupt
kein wasser drin es war ein bisschen
wasser vor dem 14 juli und dann kam das
wasser sturzbachmäßig runter und wenn
man doch mal rüber guckt auf die andere
seite dort wo jetzt diese wiese ist
standen häuser dieser häuser sind alle
abgerissen worden weil sie instabil
geworden sind die wassermassen standen
bis fast zum ende der laterne das kann
man hier vielleicht im vordergrund sehen
also diese flut werde die sich hier
durch diesen kleinen ort odendorf
ergossen hat die hat ja wirklich für
viel leid und zerstörung gesorgt und wir
waren kurz nach dem 14 ich glaube seine
zwanzigste siebte waren wir in
nordendorf und haben dort bilder
aufgenommen und die können wir jetzt
vielleicht mal einspielen und diese
bilder zeigen eigentlich wie dramatisch
die situation war also die autos lagen
wie spielzeugautos wie matchbox autos
übereinander gestapelt lagen in
hauseingängen lagen auf einem
bahnübergang der bahnübergang dort war
komplett überspült also hat die ganzen
schwellen die schienen hochgespült und
es war da wirklich an leben und wohnen
nicht zu denken und kurz nach dem 14 als
wir dort waren da waren die menschen
auch relativ verzweifelt weil sie
überhaupt natürlich keine hilfe dort
hatten also niemand hatte dort einen thw
gesehen oder andere helfer das ist ein
kleiner ort 4000 einwohner es gehört zur
gemeinde swisttal im rhein-sieg-kreis
und es war so ein bisschen der
verlassene vergessene ort und es dauert
wirklich lange bis der hilfe kam drüben
laufen die vorbereitungen für den
gottesdienst und ich versuche jetzt mal
hoch zu gehen denn dort oben sind auch
freiwillige helfer zu gange die auch an
diesem gottesdienst teilnehmen werden
wir müssen hier ein bisschen aufpassen
und müssen improvisieren weil wir ja
auch eine straße überqueren müssen und
hier an dieser kirche
ist ein infopoint eingerichtet worden
also von privatleuten die hier die
initiative ergriffen haben und gesagt
haben wir müssen hier die informationen
und bündeln wir müssen das steuern und
es muss jemanden geben der den hut auf
hat damit die leute sich an ihn wenden
können mit mit den problemen die sie
natürlich haben und hatten nach dieser
flut es sind ein paar meter hier
bekommen wir vorne wenn man da vorne
kommt an der kirche vorbei müssen hier
rechts rum und ich hoffe da ist der
kollege kai im sande der nämlich hier
die hilfe organisiert hat jetzt hier
noch auf uns wartet wir haben uns
zumindest mit ihm verabredet also bei
ihm ist flughelfer war früher bei einer
werbeagentur hat dann aber diesen job
geschmissen weil diese aufgabe die er
hier hatte wirklich so groß war und über
hand angenommen hat dass er diesen job
gar nicht mehr machen konnte hey ich hab
grad schon ein paar sätze gesagt kein im
sande ist jetzt bei uns flut verlierer
noten dafür gerne ganz rüber zum
infopoint aber das ist sozusagen die
zentrale stelle hier wo alle fäden
zusammenlaufen ich habe gerade erzählt
die bilder die wir gesehen haben mit den
autos die über den schienen lagen und
die katastrophe die sich hier ereignet
hat wie hast du das erlebt damals vor
genau einem jahr
ganz ehrlich fassungslos überhaupt nicht
greifbar und vollkommene hilflosigkeit
zu sagen ihr habt ihr euch dann sagen
wir aufgerappelt hier im ort also wie
konnte die dann die hilfe koordinieren
und auch den leuten wirklich helfen das
war absolutes chaos wie im ganzen
flutgebiet und hier auf dem platz war
der zentrale treffpunkt und dann haben
wir einfach angefangen so ein bisschen
zu koordinieren ein radlader in der
einrichtung und der lkw in der anderen
richtung funktioniert nicht und die
ganze freiwilligen helfer dazu dann
haben wir halt zusammengeführt und
gesagt fragt man in der straße an und
sowohl das sondern halt immer mehr und
mehr und mehr es gab eine zeit nach der
flut da durften die menschen auch nicht
in ihre häuser zurück als wir hatten
damals auch gedreht in heimerzheim in
der turnhalle da sind die menschen hin
gebracht worden weil sie nicht in die
häuser durften wie hat sich das dann
entwickelt in den nächsten tagen also
konnten die leute dann wieder zurück war
die sicherheit gegeben oder war hier
alles ist einmal zerstört ist montags
war alles evakuiert und unten der
rohrbachstraße war immer noch gesperrt
und dann wurden normalerweise geprüft
durch den thw und dann wurde erst wieder
wenn die leute erst wieder reingelassen
und das wurde hat auch noch mal zwei
drei tage gedauert bis sie dann wieder
drin waren dass wir dann quasi eine
woche später jetzt habt ihr ein jahr
lang hier diesen infopoint und ein jahr
lang in dem menschen auch zu euch
gekommen sind was sind jetzt noch die
probleme und visa wie weit seid ihr
gekommen eigentlich jetzt mit dem
wiederaufbau also ich finde er wieder
auf wo es sehr gut gelaufen im letzten
jahr nach startschwierigkeiten aber seit
januar auch die gelder in nrw fließen da
sehr gut das muss man sagen
die hilfe hat sich verschoben also ist
jetzt nicht mehr so überall muss der
schlamm und so woraus sondern die
menschen haben psychische probleme
probleme mit versicherungen hier und da
noch eine frage auch beim wiederaufbau
der eine oder andere suchten handwerker
also nicht oder noch eigentlich ganz
viele oder tauchen natürlich wieder neue
probleme auf und das versuchen dazu
lösungen das können wir auch da wir hier
so gut vernetzt sind auch mit den ganzen
anderen hilfsorganisationen wir wissen
halt wer helfen kann mit welchen mitteln
stimmt ihr das ja alles mittlerweile
seit dem ersten viertel werden wir auch
von hdh unterstützt aktion deutschland
hilft und können so hier auch
hauptamtlich arbeiten und das ehrenamt
damit auch noch unter uns unterstützen
und entlasten aber auch ohne das
ehrenamt geht es auch heute immer noch
nicht
und was erwartet ihr vom land vielleicht
auch von der kommune an hilfen kommt da
bass oder ist das schwierig wir haben
sehen sie schon eine gute über austausch
mittlerweile das war anfangs auch etwas
schwieriger wir erwarten dass es zügig
weiter geht die nachfrage von den
betroffenen nach aufklärung was mit
hochwasserschutz was ist mit
katastrophenschutz also was ist wenn
dies noch mal passiert auf katastrophen
nachsorge ist auch ein thema das die
menschen beschäftigt weil die ersten
zwei wochen waren die öffentlichen
stellen polizei feuerwehr thw bundes mit
waren haben geholfen das war super aber
da sagt waren die weg und das darf
einfach nicht mehr passieren und dann
erwarten die betroffen und auch die
ehrenamtliche helfer wie kriegen wir
werden sie da unterstützt wenn das noch
ist okay ich sag mal jetzt schon vielen
dank im sande hier ehrenamtlicher helfer
hier in odendorf
der gottes ist beginnt und sie sprechen
ja auch alles gute auf jeden fall für
die zukunft und hier beim wiederaufbau
und vielen dank dass ich die zeit hatten
wir nach vielen vielen dank und bleibt
stets voller zuversicht das machen wir
voller zuversicht übrigens hier das
motto was ihr auch auf allen t shirts
gedruckt ist danke schön alles gute und
mit diesen eindrücken aus odendorf gebe
ich jetzt zurück zu ali salman ich
noch nicht ganz zurück greife ich habe
noch ein paar fragen an dich denn du
hast ja auch jetzt ein jahr lang in
nordrhein-westfalen in diversen orten
die betroffenen waren gedreht hast vor
allem aber auch die politische
aufarbeitung und die her die politische
arbeit auch mit begleitet wie ist denn
da der aktuelle stand denn da ist ja
auch schon immer noch einiges sich am
tun wir haben gehört es gibt auch eben
immer noch nicht ausreichend helfen die
ausgezahlt worden sind wie ist die
politische lage aktuell in
nordrhein-westfalen in sachen
aufarbeitung der flut
ja also das ging relativ schnell nach
dem 14 17 2021 dass man im landtag
zumindest gesagt hat es muss ein
untersuchungsausschuss her und wir
müssen wirklich aufklären wie konnte es
dazu kommen warum es vielleicht an
manchen stellen nicht vernünftig gewarnt
worden welche probleme hat es im vorfeld
gegeben auch von behörden verwaltungen
etc das ist ein untersuchungsausschuss
im nordrhein westfälischen landtag
gegeben der tag der dann von september
über den dezember bis in den nordrhein
westfälischen wahlkampf hinein und das
war so ein bisschen das problem dass im
frühjahr 2022 natürlich dieser ausschuss
auch ein bisschen bestimmt war von
wahlkampfgeplänkel dann ist es
tatsächlich nicht zu einem
abschlussbericht gekommen dieses
untersuchungsausschuss man hat dann
einen zwischenbericht vorgelegt und dann
war die frage wird dieser
untersuchungsausschuss seine fortsetzung
finden und wird wirklich geklärt warum
es zu dieser katastrophe kommen konnte
und warum eben nicht gewarnt wurde und
man hat sich dann entschieden jetzt für
ein zwei wochen diesen
untersuchungsausschuss weiter zu führen
also auch unter der schwarz grünen
landesregierung vorher hatten wir eine
schwarz gelbe landesregierung und es gab
letzte woche meine ich eine
konstituierende sitzung und die
abgeordneten haben da gesagt das sind
für den menschen schuldig das erwarten
die menschen auch von uns dass wir
weitermachen und einen abschlussbericht
vorlegen weil sie wollen wissen was ist
falsch gelaufen und vor allen dingen
dann auch welche konsequenzen kann man
daraus ziehen oder sind schon auch
konsequenzen gezogen worden also die
landesregierung damals noch die
schwarz-gelbe hatte einen sogenannten
zehn-punkte-plan vorgelegt das war nicht
im januar da wurde versprochen den
hochwasserschutz zu verbessern auch die
warenketten und die meldesysteme
katastrophenschutz zu reformieren das
würde für 2022 35 millionen euro zur
verfügung gestellt und dann nochmal 100
millionen die dann später noch folgen
sollen also es ist schon was getan
worden aber die ausstellung ist noch
lange nicht am ende und der
untersuchungsausschuss wird nach der
sommerpause wieder seine arbeit
aufnehmen und dann hoffen wir dass es
irgendwann auch ein abschlussbericht
gibt und viele fragen die ist ja immer
noch gibt bei den menschen das geht dann
irgendwann auch beantwortet werden
viele offene fragen noch danke ralph
goldmann für uns in undorf in nordrhein
westfalen
und während jetzt hier in schuld wo ich
gerade stehe in odendorf voraus goldmann
war und auch in so vielen anderen orten
die gedenkgottesdienste beginnen wurde
eben den ganzen tag heute auch schon in
den betroffenen flutgebieten gedacht und
dann eine zusammenfassung des tages von
anna doda
patina amanatidis kann wieder essen
servieren ihre pizzeria in bad neuenahr
ahrweiler hat sie aus den trümmern
wieder aufgebaut mit ihrer familie und
freiwilligen helfern ich bin einfach
froh dass ich wieder ein ganz großes
stück von meinem leben zurück habe ich
kann wieder arbeiten das heißt ich kann
auch mal endlich wieder selber geld
verdienen ich kann meine miete bezahlen
und wieder zu hause wohnen aber das ist
dann auch so jetzt ist die luft
bad neuenahr-ahrweiler vor einem jahr
die größte stadt im aartal das auf rund
40 kilometern länge von der flutwelle
verwüstet wurde
135 menschen sterben in rheinland pfalz
rund 9000 gebäude werden zerstört
von den 15 milliarden euro aus dem
wiederaufbau fonds sind bisher rund 500
millionen euro ausgezahlt worden heute
besucht bundespräsident frank walter
steinmeier erneut das ahrtal
der klimawandel hat uns erreicht das
erleben wir in diesen tagen mit
hitzewellen in großen teilen
deutschlands wo wälder brennen und der
grundwasserspiegel sinkt der kampf gegen
den klimawandel hat nichts und seine
dringlichkeit verloren und dafür müssen
wir
weiterarbeiten
auch nordrhein westfalen wird schwer
getroffen 49 menschen sterben in den
fluten es sind unvorstellbare
wassermengen die ganze ortschaften
zerstören kristall bei bonn bei utah
bartels geht der wiederaufbau nur
langsam voran das zehrt an ihren kräften
ihr haus hat die flut stark beschädigt
300.000 euro schaden die zimmer der drei
kinder sind unbewohnbar stimmt es
eigentlich dass die kinder noch nicht
hier wieder wohnen können dieses
persönliche und dass man eigentlich
keine katastrophe sobald irgendwas
passiert dass man es nicht wegstecken
kann man ist einfach durch in nordrhein
westfalen stehen 12,3 milliarden euro
wiederaufbauhilfe bereit davon sind 16
milliarden euro bewilligt es liegt nicht
nur an geld dass es so lange dauert
sondern auch an fehlenden gutachtern und
dem mangel an handwerkern und
baumaterial
der wiederaufbau das haben wir heute
schon oft gehört der wäre nicht möglich
ohne die hilfe von den ganzen
freiwilligen helferinnen und helfern
teilweise auch von außerhalb und genauso
ein helfer ist jetzt stellvertretend für
die vielen helfer bei uns dennis brandt
von den dachboden schön dass du da bist
hallo
denn ist du bist gar nicht aus schuld du
wohnst hier gar nicht aber du willst
hier und zwar schon seit einem jahr hier
wirst du denn dazu gekommen genau also
wir sind vor ja fast 350 tagen hier
hingekommen einer woche nach der flut
mit sieben leuten und haben wir
angepackt und sie mittlerweile
mittlerweile über 15.000 personen tage
hier gewesen mit ganz ganz vielen
helfern die angepackt haben aus unserer
community und einfach weil wir gesehen
haben was hier zu tun ist und wir haben
angefangen spenden zu sammeln und
wollten die nach hierhin bringen und
sehen wo sie vor ort am besten
eingesetzt werden können und seitdem
sind wir hier und machen das tag für tag
ihr nehmt euch das feld normalen denn
ihr schlaft jetzt hier natürlich nicht
bei den leuten im gästezimmer denn die
gibt es ja gar nicht sondern ihr seid
ganz autark warum das zeit normal was
bedeutet das genau also dachte ja normal
ist eigentlich community die sich vorher
getroffen hat am lagerfeuer gesessen hat
und eine schöne zeit hatte und dabei
haben wir immer spenden auch gesammelt
und seitdem wir damit angefangen haben
bei uns dieser gemeinnützige charakter
sehr sehr wichtig und wir wollten immer
was gutes tun und in diesem fall haben
wir an dem wochenende nach der
katastrophe auch noch veranstaltung
gesagt wir möchten dort hinfahren hier
hinfahren und helfen und haben
mittlerweile über 53 orten in der ganzen
regierung geholfen und packen hier jeden
tag mit circa 40 bis 50 leuten am anfang
waren wir sogar bis zu 180 leute pro tag
an koordinieren die baustellen fahren
mit den autos hier hin und haben alles
an werkzeug dabei sind tag für uns mit
unseren kämpfern und habe mittlerweile
oben in europa rad auf dem berg das ist
hier in der nähe von schuld ein camp
aufgebaut komplett autark und jeder kann
dort vorbeikommen und mit anpacken und
wenn das immer ein bisschen all
inclusive helfen weil es wirklich jeder
da draußen kann und es werden immer noch
sehr viele frei die helfer auch benötigt
genau und ihr schlaft also nehme ich
deswegen hab ich angesprochen also in
dach selten auf euren band seit ganztag
seid ihr jetzt gerade im wald habt ihr
euer camp aufgeschlagen und wann warst
du das erste mal jetzt zum beispiel hier
in schuld wo wir gerade stehen und was
hast du da erlebt also hier in schuld
das erste mal runtergefahren bin hatten
wir schon einen tag in bad münstereifel
an einer schule geholfen und dann sind
wir hier runter gefahren und dieser
blick den man hier gesehen hat oder dass
das bild was ich angeboten hat das war
einfach unvorstellbar ist es gab noch
nie so was in meinem leben was ich
gesehen habe was vergleichbar war und
dann an jeder ecke war einfach die
häuser waren kaputt die menschen waren
völlig fertig einer teil wochen nach im
schlamm stehen schlamm schippen mit
eimern und so weiter und so fort und da
hatte ich das gefühl ich kann hier auch
nicht weg wir müssen hier mehr helfen
und wir haben uns immer monat für monat
gesagt kommen wir bleiben jetzt noch im
monat und helfen und dann haben wir
irgendwann doch immer gesagt wir
verbringen jetzt auf weihnachten hier
wir machen weiter und wir werden auf
jeden fall bis ende des jahres auch noch
hier sein und darüber hinaus weiter
schauen wie wir helfen können und woher
habt ihr eure fähigkeiten weil du bist
zum beispiel das erste mir verraten
eigentlich fotograf genau und wie habt
ihr euch das man muss ja auch ein
bisschen was können hier also man muss
ein bisschen
höher auf dem bau quasi fast arbeiten
wie habt ihr euch das alles an gelernt
oder kommt das einfach so das kommt
durch diese community durch dieses in
enzberg schwarm wissen also wir sind
hier hingekommen wir haben
veranstaltungen gemacht wie gesagt
vorher haben uns getroffen bis zu 4000
leute 2009 10 das letzte mal mit einer
großen gruppe und dadurch hatten wir das
know-how auf einer wiese ein camp
aufzubauen ort zu sein zu kochen
verpflegung zu schaffen und dort eine
gute zeit zu haben und das haben wir
umgesetzt und haben gesagt wir fahren
hin wir haben das know how in diesem in
diesem bereich und gucken einfach was
wir tun können wo wir anpacken können
und es hat sich für uns sehr schnell
herauskristallisiert dass wir stemmen
können dass wir den schritt raus bringen
dass wir den estrich stemmen und das
machen wir seit über 350 tagen immer
noch und haben das werkzeug über die
community bekommen alle haben was
mitgebracht jeder hat was dazu
beigetragen
und diese gemeinschaft diese solidarität
was ja auch sehr oft gesagt wird zu
sehen war überwältigend und dann haben
wir für uns diesen spruch dass wir zählt
irgendwie schon gehabt und haben dann
gemerkt hier zählt ist wirklich hier
zählt die gemeinschaft
und ich für meinen teil habe in meinem
leben noch nie etwas sinnvolles
sinnvolleres getan als hier zu helfen
und mit anzupacken und dass diese freude
und das lächeln wieder in den augen
zusehen und in den in den menschen
nachdem man dort für ein zwei tage
geholfen hat das ist mehr wert als alles
geld der welt da hast du recht und du
kriegst jetzt natürlich auch hautnah mit
hörst von den menschen hier und in den
anderen orten wo er unterwegs seid woran
es noch fehlt was würdest du aus seiner
eigenen erfahrung sagen was braucht man
hier wirklich am dringensten was
brauchen die helferinnen helfern
menschen die hier leben also man merkt
auf jeden fall dass die angst alleine
gelassen zu werden sehr sehr groß ist
dass es jetzt ein jahr nach der
katastrophe immer noch so viel zu tun
gibt die bedürfnisse sehr individuell
sind jeder ist auf dem anderen stand wir
haben teilweise häuser jetzt hier eine
straße weiter wo wir jetzt vor zwei
wochen wolfen haben der der besitzer und
im wohnwagen neben dem haus und kann
nicht ins haus zurück ist muss jetzt
leider abgerissen werden weil es
statisch nicht mehr geht und die leute
neben einfach mit dieser ungewissheit
ist braucht handwerker ist baustatiker
es braucht leute die hier sagen ich bin
für euch da es braucht auch noch
freiwillige helfer wie uns die einfach
sagen kommen wir packen mit an es gibt
so viel zu tun es gibt überall mögen
heute haben wir alleine fünf kipp
anhänger mit 30 helfern aus der immer
noch geholt und das alles fahren wir
jetzt zur deponie und entsorgen das dann
auch für noch nicht damit man sich das
mal vorstellen kann jetzt ein jahr
später was findet man denn da noch in
der alles mögliche also von mitteilte
giftige stoffe in behältern teilweise
haben wir heute gefunden auch als beste
was wir jetzt melden bei den behörden
weil es einfach sachen sind die hier
rumliegen und klar ist kümmert sich
keiner drum und so ist es auch bei den
häusern geführt dass viel leid hinter
den fassaden nicht die betroffenen
vielleicht auch die scham hatten haben
oder auch selber bis jetzt nicht selber
was tun konnten weil es die emotionale
belastung so hoch war dass das haus
einfach nicht wieder aufgebaut werden
konnte oder teilweise auch gewartet wird
auf gutachten das die versicherung auf
sich warten lassen oder teilweise auch
ganz bezahlen also sind so viele
prozesse die laufen und da muss man sehr
sehr individuell gerade helfen weil es
nicht wie am anfang wo man hinkommt und
holt den schlamm raus da war klar was
getan werden muss jetzt muss jeder
betroffene hier am besten auch die
einzelnen individuelle betreuung
bekommen wie er gerade braucht in seinem
stadion
gleichzeitig werde es am anfang der
sendung von familie die gehört gibt es
auch die die schon so weit sind dass sie
in den häusern sind es geschafft haben
das waren für mich immer ganz bewegende
momente zu sehen wie weit die idee es
schon gekommen sind was hat dich auch in
diesem jahr so richtig gepackt und
berührt also die geschichten zu hören
wenn leute wieder demut passen
weiterzumachen zu sagen es geht vorwärts
ist passiert was und wir können jetzt
wieder hoffnung schöpfen die da unser
haus aufzubauen auch bei familie die
haben wir jetzt letztens noch geholfen
im hotel mit studenten die hier
vorbeigekommen sind aus düsseldorf die
mit angepackt haben und einfach die
diese gemeinschaft zu sehen und diese
freude die man weitergeben kann weil es
ist nicht die arbeit die wir hier einen
stuhl sondern das was wir den menschen
geben und diese hoffnung mit zu geben
dass das nicht alleine seit das ist das
was zählt aber sagt vielleicht noch für
einen jene die auch überlegen ob sie
irgendwann mal mithelfen können du
machst das jetzt hauptberuflich das habe
ich verstanden überhaupt ehrenamtlich
kann man aber auch einfach mal nur einen
tag mitmachen wie läuft das genau ab
also man kommt bei uns hin man kann sich
vorher anmelden auf der webseite und man
packt dann einfach mit alles an was man
also tun kann die haben auch leute die
einfach natürlich mithelfen die essen
vorbereiten und jeder kann das tun was
er gut kann und wir leiten es auch sehr
an also ist es sehr wichtig dass die
helfer die dort ihr psa dann auch
bekommen also persönliche
schutzausrüstung dass da niemand zu
schaden kommt eine maske auch kriegt die
passenden schuhe arbeitskleidung und
anleiten wir von vorne bis hinten gehen
auf die baustelle und jeder kann dann
dort auch lernen einfach zu stemmen oder
den estrich ross zu machen das ist
wirklich unter anleitung kinderleicht
und wenn es halt so all inclusive helfen
also wir haben von von 17 18 19 bis
aufwärts 70-80 welche dabei zum beispiel
der erich der vom chiemsee jedes
wochenende zu uns kommt und die 700 800
kilometer fährt um dann hier mit
anzupacken und so kann halt jeder da
draußen einfach das auch tun jeder kann
das auch tun hören wir von dennis brandt
von den derzeit normalen der hier seit
einem jahr in der ganzen region hilft
vielen dank dass du heute bei uns zu
gast
und jetzt zum ende der sendung wollen
wir schalten live nach euskirchen denn
dort warten wir jetzt schon eine weile
auf die rede des bundespräsidenten von
frank walter steinmeier
jetzt gleich beginnen und deswegen gebe
ich ja flügel ab nach euskirchen
heute ist ein tag des innehaltens und
der trauer
es ist ein tag an dem für sie alle die
angst und das grauen zurückkommen
es ist ein tag an dem der schmerz
wir kommen zu ertragen ist
mehr als 180 menschen verloren in der
nacht des 14 juli
2021 hier in nordrhein westfalen und
drüben in rheinland-pfalz erleben
sie die sie heute hier zu diesem
gedenkgottesdienst zusammen gekommen
sind
haben ihre liebsten
nachbarn
freunde verloren
nichts ist in ihrem leben wie zuvor
heute an diesem tag
gedenken wird der toten
die opfer bleiben und vergessen wir
trauern gemeinsam
und vereint
und als bundespräsident möchte ich ihnen
sagen sie sind nicht allein
nie werden sie vergessen kann was in
jener nacht des 14 juli jener nacht des
grauens geschah
als kleine bäche zu ungeheuren ans
wollen die alles mit sich rissen
in ihrem leben
war das ein furchtbarer schlag eine
zutiefst traumatische erfahrung viele
von ihnen
haben alles verloren ihre häuser ihren
besitz ihre erinnerungen ihre
lebensträume
ihre existenz
wie groß der schmerz ihre verzweiflung
war
wie sie war und vielleicht immer noch
ist
was sie in jener nacht und in den
monaten seither durchlitten haben
das kann ich nur erahnen und nichts kann
ihnen ihren schmerz nehmen
ich bin heute aber auch hier um ihnen zu
sagen ich bin
beeindruckt dass
sie trotz der zerstörung trotz ihrer
verzweiflung nicht aufgegeben haben hier
ist ihre heimat
so empfinden es die meisten von ihnen
hier ist mein leben und hier soll es
bleiben
so sagen viele und deshalb haben sie
angepackt und sich gegenseitig geholfen
die schlimmsten verwüstungen beseitigt
mit dem wiederaufbau begonnen
die furchtbare zerstörung die das wasser
zurück ließ
sie ist bis heute sichtbar und es wird
vermutlich noch jahre dauern bis sie
ganz beseitigt ist
sichtbar ist aber auch was sie geleistet
haben im vergangenen jahr und davor
habe ich ganz enormen respekt ich möchte
ihnen allen hier in dieser kirche und
allen menschen die von dieser
schlimmsten hochwasserkatastrophe seit
jahrzehnten heimgesucht wurden heute
danke ich danke ihnen
für ihre kraft
ihren einsatz
ihre solidarität ich danke auch allen
professionellen und freiwilligen helfern
die in der stunde der not sofort aus
allen teilen deutschlands angereist sind
und den menschen hier beigestanden haben
und viele es bis heute noch tun
und mein dank geht an die
bürgermeisterin bürgermeistern die
landrätinnen und landräte an diejenigen
die in den verwaltungen arbeiten sie
alle haben in diesen vergangenen zwölf
monaten schier unglaubliches geschuldet
sicher wussten viele oft nicht wo
anfangen
und wo aufhören wenn dann tausend dinge
zur gleichen zeit getan werden muss den
verzweifelten helfen
gutachten einholen baugenehmigung
erteilen orte teilweise ganz neu planen
und ich kann mir auch vorstellen dass
manche von ihnen
manche von den betroffenen
ungeduldig sind dass sie das gefühl
haben
dass vieles zu lange dauert zu langsam
vorangeht
das habe ich heute morgen auch im alltag
gehört
ja
vieles ist getan
aber noch mehr bleibt zu tun
die bundesregierung und die länder haben
sehr schnell sehr umfangreiche hilfs
fonds aufgelegt um den menschen in den
katastrophengebieten zu helfen hilfe
dort zu leisten wo sie so bitter nötig
ist und weiter bleibt bei den
betroffenen nämlich meine dringende
bitte an alle die verantwortung tragen
ist lassen sie nicht nach in ihren
anstrengungen
damit den menschen
effektiv und unbürokratisch geholfen
wird und
ich kann mir auch vorstellen dass sie
eine frage immer noch quält wie war es
möglich wie konnte das passieren warum
wurde nicht schnell und umfassend genug
gewarnt ich glaube diese frage
müssen wir uns als ganzes land stellen
was kann was muss besser werden beim
katastrophenschutz und die können wir
uns in zukunft besser schützen eine
antwort auf diese frage müssen sie hier
in euskirchen den benachbarten
landkreisen
ganz konkret beim wiederaufbau finden
aber wir müssen
das ist das wichtige auch als ganzes
land eine antwort darauf suchen und
finden was zu tun ist und das möglichst
rasch
aber besserer schutz und bessere
vorsorge das wird nicht ausreichen wir
wissen die folgen des klimawandels haben
uns in europa und hier in deutschland
längst erreicht auch in diesem sommer
sehen wir dramatische bilder
aus italien wurde der norden
wortwörtlich austrocknet aus portugal
das landesweite notstand ausgerufen hat
aus den alpen wo riesige gletscher teile
abbrechen und alles unter sich begraben
und auch bei uns
herrscht im vierten sommer in folge vor
allem in regionen im osten deutschlands
besorgniserregende trockenheit brennen
die wälder sinken die grundwasserpegel
während andere landesteile von schweren
unwettern heimgesucht
werden
solche extremen wetterlagen auch das
wissen wir
werden in zukunft mit großer
wahrscheinlichkeit immer wieder
eintreten und das ist eine folge des
globalen klimawandels wir müssen jede
aber auch wirklich jede anstrengung
unternehmen um die folgen des
klimawandels zu bekämpfen und wir müssen
viel umfassender vorsorge treffen um
unseren kindern und enkeln
einen lebenswerten planeten zu
hinterlassen
meine damen und herren
als bundespräsident weiß ich aber auch
in der stunde der not sind wie ein
starkes ein solidarisches land während
und nach der flut haben wir es uns
erneut bewiesen wir stehen zusammen
wenn es darauf ankommt
das schafft zuversicht für zeiten die
uns weiter fordern werden
und die nicht einfacher werden
heute aber bin ich hier
um mit ihnen gemeinsam zu bedenken und
zu trauern
und auch im namen so viele unserer
landsleute
versichere ich ihnen
sie sind nicht allein
danke
das war der bundestrend das war der
bundespräsident frank walter steinmeier
heute zum gedenken an diesem tag ein
jahr nach der flutkatastrophe und wir
kommen jetzt auch zum ende an diesem tag
und danke für eure aufmerksamkeit danke
dass ihr zugeschaut habe ich glaube
haben alle hier nochmal viel gelernt
auch gerade hier von den menschen live
aus schuld von wo wir berichtet haben
aber natürlich auch von allen anderen
orten wo wir die möglichkeit heute
hatten die geschichten zu hören von all
jenen die betroffen sind würde gerne
noch einen kommentar von euch zum ende
aufgreifen denn viele haben geschrieben
und ich habe ihn gleich auch zur hand
viele haben geschrieben wie zb auch
feierabend 1 bei youtube danke alles
gute und viel kraft den betroffenen und
überlebenden dieser flut katastrophe
wenn viel kraft wird das auch noch
brauchen der wiederaufbau dauert an und
viel kraft haben die menschen hier auch
schon gegeben und gezeigt wir wünschen
ihnen dabei weiterhin alles gute vielen
dank dass ihr dabei wart danke und
tschüss